Dan:
I need to be that guy
one last time-
for us.
[screaming and falling]
[music starts]
[bike bell ringing]
Oh hey Dan!
Happy Anniversary!
Dan, my husband, he's an amazing dad.
Dan:
You're almost ready to
go a to size 4S, huh?
Ah, you so big. Look at the big musckuls.
I just wish our lives were...
Jess:
Bigger.
[glass cracks]
[kicks]
Really?
At least let me put my kid down.
[fighting]
[cart crashes]
[baby laughing]
Store Employee:
Clean up on aisle 6.
Sorry about the mess.
[car screeches]
Hold on.
[car drifting]
Oh hey Beau.
Hey Dan.
Don't hang up.
I need new identities, I'm burned.
Dan:
Me, my wife, and three kids.
Have you told them yet?
I'll tell them when I'm on the road,
meet me in Vegas in three days.
This is crazy!
Oh my God! We're going to Vegas!
-Woo!
-Oh, so pumped.
Nothing brings the family
together like a road trip.
Jess and Dan:
♪ Stop! Collaborate and listen! ♪
♪ Ice is back with a brand new invention.
Jess and Dan:
♪ Something grabs a hold of me tightly- ♪
Please stop.
[baby laughing]
Five hours on a plane or
thirty-three hours in a car?
Can someone unlock the car please?
[glass breaks]
Call in everybody.
[engine revs]
McCaffrey:
I want him found.
Baby Max:
Da-da.
[assassin gagging]
[baby laughing]
What was that?!
A little pothole.
Maxey has been up
the whole time by the way.
[gunshots breaking glass]
[fighting]
Where's dad?
[kicking impacts]
Dan:
Before I met your mom I was
a covert assassin.
I escaped that life and now they found us.
[all laughing]
[gunshots]
What the-
Being your husband and their father,
that's the real me.
[engine revs]
[gunshot]
You're like James Bond in a minivan!
I love that minivan.
Da-da da-da.
[baby laughing]
I need to be that guy one last time,
for us.
[gunshots]
[fighting]
[screaming and falling]
♪ Ice ice baby ♪
Look at you playing the family man.
Dan:
I'm not playing.
This is my life.
[cheering]
[gunshot and explosion]
Bang.
I'm kinda into spontaneous Dan.
Wait. wait.
[baby laughing]
Go!
[rapid diaper changing]
Mwa!
New record!